went very fast 30 years went much faster
than many people would imagine you know
some people to achieve variety in their
career will move from one company to
another and find that what they're doing
is they're asked to do the same thing
that they did the previous company do
that again for us during my 30 years I
had the ability to have at least seven
or eight separate and distinct careers
because I would master something decide
that that was great but I'd like to try
something else and the IBM company is
diverse enough and interesting enough
and and flexible enough that if you
express that interest they let you go
take it I in the last 20 years out of a
30-year career I actually never took
another person's job I stopped looking
for jobs and started to create roles
roles that I would be interested in and
that's kind of the dirty secret of
Kevin's career at IBM is that they were
kind of paying me to do what I like to
do anyway and now I'm continuing to do
that on my own
one of the mistakes that that was made
and I was just talking about this at
lunch with someone in fact was you know
not taking full advantage when we
reorganized of the chaos you know
sometimes you would land another area
and you would have had the ability to
maybe make a different kind of change
and you didn't really act fast enough to
take it you know advantage of the chaos
and sometimes you would end up reporting
to someone that you didn't know almost
every time that I was discouraged in my
career it was because I was working with
someone where we had a little bit of
friction I kind of agree with the phrase
you know people don't quit companies
they quit managers right and you know
those are the times when I should have
acted a little bit more quickly to get
into a good situation I started to get
much better of that later in my career
than i was earlier
gives the worst advice that I received
all right was you need to become
extremely deep in one thing and become
good at that and stick with it forever
and although I have developed some areas
of expertise where I'm known really the
strength of of my background a career is
through the diversity of things that I'm
interested in that I continue to you
know to learn and I never considered my
education to end you know I actually
have started a group where we teach each
other I knew that my executive education
days were over in professional education
so I've started my own professional
education self-help group and you know
by looking at many many things and
continuing to include and transcend
known categories it keeps me fresh keeps
me interested in what I'm doing and
makes me more valuable to the clients
that I serve and just keeps me energized
right for waking up and tackling the day
I remember you know several managers
that were quite good we'd just gone
through one of the rear organizations
that we talked about this particular
gentleman SAT me down and and said I
don't know who you are or why you're
reporting to me now but I just have a
few things that I want to share with you
early on I have every confidence that
you're going to do find here because we
hire great people in this company
however I've got two relationships with
you the first one is professional the
second one is personal and in our
professional life you're either going to
do great here and I'll you know
appraised and rate you accordingly or if
not i'll let you know and then on the
personal side where they're going to get
along we're going to be friends or i'm
not going to like you and that's all
right because if you're doing a good job
and I don't like you you'll still get
the raises you'll still get the
performances but if I do like you and
you're not doing the work you'll get
that right signal too so I thought that
was a very clear three-minute
description or less of what it was going
to be like what his expectations were
and it just imprinted on me I'd still
remember those few first few minutes
with him and thinking how clear that was
I immediately stole it and use it as I
became a manager right for the people
who came to work for me
you